SO THE REDEFINITION NEVER ENDS
IN THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
GREAT TO SEE YOU AS ALWAYS.
LAST MONTH, BIDEN NOMINATED A
RADICAL ARIZONA BASED LAWYER TO
THE NINTH CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS.
SO WHO EXACTLY IS SHE?
>> YOU ARGUED THAT IT WOULD BE A
PROBLEM TO EXTEND AN EXEMPTION
ON THE GROUNDS OF RELIGIOUS
FREEDOM TO A PARTICULAR SMALL
BUSINESS.
>> YOU'VE BEEN VERY ACTIVE IN AN
ORGANIZATION THAT FIGHTS AGAINST
SCHOOL CHOICE IN ARIZONA.
>> YOUR CHOSEN AREA OF THE LAW
THAT REALLY REQUIRES YOU TO WEAR
JERSEY.
>> YOU CLEARLY DO HAVE A LIBERAL
WORLDVIEW.
>> Laura: LIBERAL WORLDVIEW,
THAT'S AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
AS FIRST REPORTED BY FOX
DIGITAL, SHE SERVES ON THE BOARD
OF JUST COMMUNITIES ARIZONA.
IT'S A GROUP WHOSE MISSION IT IS
TO CREATE A WORLD FREE OF
PRISONS AND PUNISHMENT.
SO HOW DO YOU SERIOUSLY CONSIDER
HAVING SOMEONE ON THE BENCH WHO
DOESN'T SEEM TO BELIEVE IN OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM?
THAT'S WILD EVEN FOR THE NINTH
CIRCUIT.
SHE ALSO WORKED AS AN ATTORNEY
FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD HELPED
LAUNCHED THE STATES CREATION A
MARIJUANA PROGRAM, SHE'S A REAL
GEM.
HERE NOW IS MIKE DAVISON, FORMER
CHIEF COUNSEL FOR NOMINATIONS TO
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
GREAT TO SEE YOU IN STUDIO.
WHY IS THIS NOMINATION TO THE
COURT OF APPEALS SO BAD AND WHY
DOES IT HAVE TO BE STOPPED?
>> THIS ONE IS PARTICULARLY BAD.
OUT OF ALL THE BIDEN NOMINEES,
SHE IS RIGHT UP THERE WITH ONE
OF THE WORST.
SHE'S WORKED WITH GEORGE SOROS,
THE ACLU, PLANNED PARENTHOOD,
OPEN BORDERS GROUP, THE TEACHERS
UNIONS, SHE'S ADVOCATED FOR
ABOLISHING PRISONS, DEFUNDING A
POLICE, MASK MANDATES IN
SCHOOLS, CRT IN SCHOOLS, SHE'S A
LEFT-WING RADICAL.
>> Laura: THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
ISSUE, THAT IN AND OF ITSELF
SEEMS TO BE A DISQUALIFIER.
SHE DOESN'T BELIEVE IN PRISONS,
AND SHE DOESN'T BELIEVE IN
PUNISHMENT BURIED HOW TO USE IT
AS A FEDERAL APPELLATE COURT
JUDGE IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE ANY
BETTER OF THOSE THINGS?
>> YOU DON'T.
AND SHE ALSO THINK THAT OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
RACIST, AND SO SHE'S GOING TO
HAVE A HARD TIME DOING HER JOB.
>> Laura: NOW, INSTEAD OF
PRESSING ON ANY ONE OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT WE TALKED ABOUT,
HERE'S HOW SECRETARY -- SENATOR,
EXCUSE ME, CORY BOOKER, USED HIS
TIME DURING THE CONFIRMATION
HEARING.
WATCH.
>> YOU CAN REST, BECAUSE I JUST
WANT TO TALK TO YOU FOR A FEW
MINUTES, I DO NOT QUESTIONS.
I JUST WANT TO TELL YOU BOTH HOW
GRATEFUL I AM THAT YOU'RE HERE,
HOW GRATEFUL I AM TO THE
PRESIDENT FOR NOMINATING YOU.
I THINK WE ARE PRIVILEGED TO
HAVE YOU BEFORE US, YOU ARE BOTH
COMPETENT JURISTS.
YOU BOTH HAVE DEMONSTRATED
YOURSELF TO BE TRULY QUALIFIED.
>> Laura: MIKE, SPARTACUS HAD
A LOT OF QUESTIONS THERE.
THERE'S NO -- THERE'S NO CONCERN
AT ALL FOR OVERSIGHT
QUALIFICATIONS -- BUT THIS IS
WHAT GOT THEM IN TROUBLE WITH
KAMALA HARRIS.
AND NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO PUT
THIS OTHER WOMAN ON THE
NINTH CIRCUIT, AND IT'S GOING TO
RUN INTO OTHER PROBLEMS.
DO YOU THINK SOMEONE LIKE
JOE MANCHIN WOULD SUPPORT THIS?
>> WHAT'S SURPRISING IS THESE
TWO ARIZONA SENATORS WHO ARE
SUPPORTING THIS NOMINEE IN
ARIZONA, KYRSTEN SINEMA AND MARK
KELLY, SUPPOSED BE MODERATE.
>> Laura: MODERATE!
>> THERE ARE FAR FROM ULTIMATE
TO MODERATE.
WHEN IT COMES TO LIFETIME
APPOINTMENTS ON THE CRITICAL
JUST TO VOTE IN LOCKSTEP WITH
ALL THESE OTHER RADICALS.
>> Laura: WEBMASTERS, WILL
PROBABLY BE THE NOMINEE TO GO UP
AGAINST KELLY, THIS IS A MAJOR
ISSUE IN THE CAMPAIGN.
OR IT SHOULD BE.
>> IT IS.
THIS NOMINEE SERVES ON THE BOARD
WHERE THEY MOURN THE EXECUTION
OF A MAN WHO KIDNAPPED AND
MURDERED AN 8-YEAR-OLD.
>> Laura: IN SEPTEMBER OF
2021, SHE ARGUED AGAINST A
PROVISION THAT WOULD BAN MASK
MANDATES, THE SCHOOLS SAYING
THIS CHILDREN WILL SUFFER IF
THAT PROVISION BECOMES LAW.
GREAT MANY CHILDREN IN ARIZONA
SHE SAID LOOK AT COVID.
THEY WILL GET LONG COVID, THEY
WILL BE HOSPITALIZED, AND THEY
WILL DIE.
SHE SAYS THAT IS NOT HYPERBOLE.
MIKE, OBVIOUSLY SHE WAS
COMPLETELY WRONG, BUT SHE WAS
SCARING PEOPLE.
>> SHE DOES NOT HAVE A JUDGMENT
TO BE ON THE NINTH CIRCUIT AND
THE TWO ARIZONA BASED SENATORS,
KYRSTEN SINEMA, MARK KELLY, HAVE
MADE A VERY BAD DECISION HERE BY
ADVOCATING FOR THIS.
>> Laura: THIS IS WHY SAY THEY
IDEA OF A MODERATE DEMOCRAT IS A
UNICORN.
OCCASIONALLY JOE MANCHIN WILL DO
THE RIGHT THING, THANK GOODNESS,
AND OCCASIONAL KYRSTEN SINEMA
WILL AS WELL.
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE TYPES OF
RADICAL A POINT -- THEY RUN FOR
THE HILLS.
>> THESE DEMOCRATS ABOUT 100% OF
THE TIME FOR THESE